the family of former President Jimmy
Carter has revealed that his wife former
first lady Rosalind Carter has been
diagnosed with dementia 95 year old Mrs
Carter remains at home with her husband
who is 98. the former president began
receiving Hospice Care earlier this year
during and after his presidency Roseland
Carter became one of the country's
leading mental health advocates in a
statement The Carter family noted her
lifelong work writing there are only
four kinds of people in this world those
who have been caregivers those who are
currently caregivers those who will be
caregivers and those who will need
caregivers the universality of
caregiving is clear in our family and we
are experiencing the joy and the
challenges of this journey
these beautiful people and the longest
marriage in U.S presidential history
they met when he was three and she was
just a day old because Jimmy's mother
cared for her she was a nurse caregiving
runs in the family